buonasera buonasera a tutti
devo dire che chiudere un evento come
questo con tutti questi contenuti è
abbastanza terrorizzante comunque io
quello che vorrei fare questa questo
pomeriggio e di portarvi all'interno
ragionamento tra la creatività perché
quando mi chiedono dove nascono le opere
di solito rispondo che quando lo capirò
cambierò mestiere lo rassicuro tutti
quanti non l'ho ancora capito per cui va
bene e continuerò a fare a fare il mio
mestiere però vorrei portarvi in questo
processo di avvicinamento di
comprensione di che cos'è cos'è la
creatività e partirei con l'idea della
destituzione cioè e quella creatività
come unire elementi esistenti no
con connessioni nuovo berfin che siano
utili
interessante steve jobs molto più
pratico dice mettere insieme le cose il
concetto è però che qualcosa che ci
serve per vivere e quindi attraverso la
quotidianità non è qualcosa che serve
per fare il quale o per essere un
pubblicitario è qualcosa che ci serve
per vivere
ci viene in aiuto anche l'etimologia
karar cioè
generare fabbricare
unendo unendo in maniera nuovo in
maniera interessante e quindi
praticamente ogni volta che facciamo
qualcosa di nuovo noi facciamo qualcosa
di creativo
impariamo già due cose ora sentiamo su
due cose importanti
1 tutti siamo creati
v2 è qualcosa che permea la nostra
quotidianità non è qualcosa che è altro
al di fuori di noi sa qualcosa che
all'interno di noi e questa cosa
smaschera me è da tenere in
considerazione tutti siamo creativi
essere creativi vuol dire maneggiare il
cambiamento avere a che fare con l'idea
di cambiare cambiare spaventa non
bisogna avere paura di fallire quindi
bisogna mettersi in gioco e quindi per
essere creativi bisogna essere
coraggiosi quindi la creatività non al
di fuori di noi ma la creatività
all'interno
del nostro modo di vedere le cose
che cosa innesca il processo creativo
lo innesca la necessità
tutto quello che
mancanza disagio e soddisfazione diventa
quell'elemento che ci spinge a voler
cambiare a voler innescare un processo
di cambiamento che avviene attraverso la
creatività questa cosa estremamente
importante quando ero al liceo liceo
periodo particolare periodo dove tutto
capita dove tu inconsciamente sai che
sei in continuo movimento in continuo
cambiamento quindi non ti poni il
problema di cambiare tipo di problemi
dove andare e mi ripetevo sempre per
arrivare all'alba non esiste che la
notte magari quando facevo la notte per
studiare la tv ma che non l'avevo fatto
il giorno prima prima serve un tè che
parlava di procrastinare vero
importantissimo prendersi tutti i tempi
possibili ad ogni modo per essere
creativi bisogna affrontare la realtà
allora qui parlo del primo lavoro che
peraltro coincide con il primo lavoro
musealizzato dei miei si chiama we wall
uguale wall noi siamo il muro in questo
caso il tema è il messaggio era
la celebrazione della caduta del muro di
berlino con l'idea che trasformare il
muro di berlino in specchio ci facesse
rendere conto che i muri in natura non
esistono esistono solo perché creati
dall'uomo quindi il vero muro siamo noi
sui nostri pregiudizi e la nostra
cultura la nostra incapacità di mettersi
in discussione che crea delle barriere
contro gli altri ma in questo contesto
in questo ragionamento sulla creatività
significa che noi dobbiamo essere in
grado di guardare la realtà di
affrontare quello che capita e anche di
demolire quel che muro quindi di far
cadere qualche certezza per poter far
spazio spazio al nuovo nuovo che ha a
che fare con un concetto importante di
crisi crisi creatività hanno la stessa
raddrizza radice la crisi che cos'è
fondamentalmente quella sensazione quel
momento che anticipa al cambiamento o
che lo segue quando il cambiamento viene
anticipata dalla crisi lo induce la
crisi quando invece segue perché è
accaduto qualcosa e noi dobbiamo rendere
conto che qualcosa è cambiato
quindi il
sarà la crisi che significa
fondamentalmente
valutare e poi separare insieme alla per
la creatività che invece significa
creare nel nuovo mettendo insieme ecco
questi due elementi insieme solo un
sistema fondamentalmente in equilibrio
instabile in continua successione molto
veloce no e questa successione
è quella che sostiene la capacità di
adattamento dell'uomo e la capacità
dell'uomo di affrontare la vita di
affrontare quello che ci capita di
rinnovare e di evolvere di evolvere come
individuo ma anche poi di evolvere di
evolvere come società e questo
estremamente interessante e importante
perché essere creativi quindi significa
saper amministrare e governare il
proprio disagio
inteso come forza creativa cioè essere
capaci di fare i conti con noi stessi e
di trasformare questa questa energia
questa mancanza
questo disagio questo problema in
opportunità e saperla portare avanti in
maniera creativa per cambiare quello che
non ci piace e qualche cosa che in a
livello istintivo noi facciamo poi però
per paura ci blocchiamo perché l'invito
e quello invece proprio di di farle cioè
per essere creativo non è soltanto un
qualcosa che si impara certo si può si
può stimolare si può imparare dei dei
processi per aumentare la creatività ma
nella realtà il problema e accettare il
cambiamento accettare di dover andare
oltre e quindi più che un più che un
qualcosa più di un esercizio secondo me
è un modo di vivere un modo di essere ed
è
questa binomio
crisi cambiamento crisi creatività in
realtà è anche quello che ha dato il via
a tutto quella che è la mia estetica di
cui parlava irene quest'opera si chiama
lepri della via è stata realizzata nel
2013 per la biennale di venezia dedicata
a mia madre che è scomparsa nel 2012
proprio perché mi hanno chiesto un
lavoro sulla crisi e va bene insomma la
perdita di un genitore è della mamma poi
in particolare è l'elemento di crisi
secondo me più più importante che possa
capitare secondo natura
in quell'occasione ho ragionato detto
crisi crisi in realtà cambiamento cioè
qualcosa che si è modificato che io non
prevederlo e qui devo adeguarmi
quindi anche opportunità un po
giapponese come idea e ha detto ma quale
l'espressione formale della crisi per me
è la piega
della giudizio del cambiamento per me è
la piega la materia va in una direzione
accade qualcosa va inevitabilmente in un
altra da lì ho deciso di descrivere
tutti i miei soggetti attraverso delle
più nelle pieghe queste piede sono le
cicatrici sono le decisioni le cose che
ci accadono come noi decidiamo di
reagire
sono quegli elementi che poi ci rendono
unici e che quindi rendono unici anche i
soggetti della mia arte la cosa
interessante è che quest'opera poi è
stata realizzata anche in una dimensione
più monumentale ed è stata inserita come
opera principale all'interno della
ammiraglia di costa crociere che si
chiama costa smeralda proprio nella
prima nave che proprio a all'interno una
collezione dedicata alla creatività in
questo caso made in italy ma è
interessante capire come quelle cose in
una qualche misura qualche maniera
ritornano sono circolari rientrano
all'interno poi il secondo elemento che
mi piaceva indagare era il rapporto tra
creatività immaginazione
quello che serve per fare i quali spesso
e l'immaginazione la capacità cioè di
sognare la capacità di andare oltre la
capacità di proporre scenari e soluzioni
alternative a qualcosa di noto e questo
è un fattore di innesco è un fattore
iniziale alla creatività immaginazione e
l'inizio della creazione le persone
immaginano quello che desiderano poi
vogliono quello che immagino e alla fine
creano quello che vogliono è importante
questa relazione perché dà un senso no a
tutto il processo come per le opere che
ho realizzato che si chiamano frame dove
è l'assenza dell'opera finita che
innesca il processo di immaginazione e
di creatività quindi quando uno guarda
un'opera che in divenire che non è un
non finito
completarlo con la propria fantasia con
le proprie emozioni con la propria
esperienza in quel modo si innesta un
modo differente di vedere l'arte una
differenza importante per l'opera che
abbiamo visto prima che è racchiuso
nella sua se vogliamo per sezione a
specchio questa è un divenire un
qualcosa che coinvolge un modo per
entrare all'interno del processo
creativo di condividerlo con le persone
che che lo guardano e riguardano l'opera
finita
il secondo elemento per me è molto
interessante è stato indagare il
rapporto tra creatività e semplicità
branco si diceva che la creatività nella
la semplicità nell'arte e complessità
risolta questo è importante
semplice non dire essenziale non vuol
dire facile la semplicità è un fattore
un traguardo è un elemento da
raggiungere è un obiettivo da ottenere e
si ottiene attraverso la comprensione
della complessità
l'elaborazione di quella complessità per
poi arrivare ad un riassunto doppia
personale allora questo è un processo
creativo no io
assorbo delle informazioni
mi guardo attorno e poi ne restituiscono
una interpretazione quanto più semplice
tanto più poi diventa facile da
comunicare intuitiva e quindi capace di
trasmettere proprio il proprio messaggio
per esempio io ho avuto l'opportunità di
partecipare a un evento straordinario al
teatro del silenzio con andrea bocelli
questa valle si chiama valdera un
architetto l'architetto bartalini che ha
inventato il teatro del silenzio un
giorno si è seduto qui davanti ha detto
ma perché questa valle non può diventare
un teatro un teatro per un evento
straordinario
fondamentalmente la cosa è semplice e
poi è stato complicato realizzarlo
allo stesso modo questa è l'opera che io
ho realizzato per questo evento allo
stesso modo
anch'io andando lì mi sono detto ma ma
in questo luogo non può esserci altro
che non un'opera che parli di uomo che
parli di divino vista la straordinaria
bellezza del luogo e che in qualche modo
li mette in relazione quindi ho creato
quest'opera che si chiama gabriel in
realtà è un pugile che un uomo nella sua
posizione anche forte quasi giudicante a
specchio quindi in questa accezione
abbiamo visto prima chiusa quasi divina
quasi da osservare che però ha le ali in
ferro in ferrazzo arrugginito perché
perché le ali rappresentano lo strumento
che quell'uomo ha costruito per sé per
andare oltre i propri limiti
shechter evolvere per continuare ad
andare verso qualcosa di diverso
qualcosa nel quale lui si sente più a
suo agio quindi qui c'è il dialogo che
poi è quello di cui parlavamo prima un
dialogo creativo verso la vita verso la
possibilità di fare e dicevo
l'intuizione è semplice però poi la
realizzazione è difficile questo è il
concerto che abbiamo realizzato e che
hanno quali sco partecipato a mettere in
piedi una cosa del genere ci sono più di
mille persone che lavorano per per quasi
un mese trasformare una valle in un in
un palcoscenico straordinario per due
ore di concerto con 20mila persone che
lo guardano è qualcosa che semplice
nell'idea ma poi è difficile
parimenti l'opera che sembra piccola
all'interno di un contesto naturale è
un'opera di 16 metri è difficile da
realizzare da ingegnerizzare visto in
proporzione con l'uomo non è una cosa
facile non è una cosa semplice non vuol
dire facile no e questo è importante poi
c'è un altro tema straordinario che il
rapporto con il limite la creatività
abbiamo detto la capacità di prendere
degli elementi e trasformarli in
qualcosa di nuovo che ci piace bene
allora il limite è lo stimolo è quello
che crea il disagio è l'elemento che noi
vogliamo contrastare
le regole sono l'ambiente all'interno in
cui noi abbiamo l'opportunità di
dimostrare la nostra creatività
no e poi la conoscenza sono le
mattonelle cioè sono gli elementi che
noi possiamo ricombinare per tirare
qualcosa che ci è più adatto
l'intelligenza creativa non è in
contrasto con l'intelligenza
disciplinata perché senza disciplina non
si perviene alla creatività ma si resta
a quello stadio infantile che è la
spontaneità che ancora meno
dell'immaginazione e semplicemente
quell'elemento del bambino allora certo
un obiettivo dell'arte può essere quello
di ottenere di arrivare alla spontaneità
ma come risultato di un processo molto
importante molto lungo molto faticoso e
molto interiorizzato
i limiti per me sono elementi che mi
permettono di lavorare in questo
contesto con le aziende
io ho un progetto si chiama arte azienda
territorio l'idea di mettere in linea
attraverso l'arte le aziende i valori
dell'azienda sul territorio come cultura
territoriale e il territorio stesso come
genius loci cioè questi due elementi
devono parlare perché rappresenta la
nostra storia la nostra identità e
arrivano ad essere dei monumenti questo
per esempio sto realizzato via
dell'acqua mantio per la gastronomia
mosca 1916
come si applica la creatività questo è
una molecola d'acqua
che ha degli elementi chiusi per
proteggere le eccellenze di un
territorio degli elementi aperti per
favorire lo scatto quindi un simbolo che
rappresenta il concetto di essere e di
rimanere eccellenti per il committente
ma anche per il territorio
un altro esempio è sento sempre
realizzato sul territorio di biella per
cna l'associazione artigiana mi hanno
chiesto per i 30 anni di interpretare
l'artigiano il lavoro artigiano e
l'artigiano per me è un bambino che con
la sua innocenza continua a scoprire
nuove soluzioni con grande creatività
perché a quel coraggio di mettersi in
gioco di iniziare qualcosa anche se non
sa dove va a finire di inventarsi un
giorno qualcosa di nuovo poi per il
mondo dell'artigianato un tema
importante e proprio anche quello della
dell'eredità solo di lasciare qualche
cosa non solo in termini di capacità
artigianale ma in termini proprio di di
di possibilità di
condividere di lasciarlo alle persone un
altro elemento è questo importantissimo
gigante per la coppa del mondo di sci un
po più iconico e vado veloce questo
iconico anche per coca cola per i 100
anni di coca cola nel 2000 e 2015 della
bottiglia contour
intuizione che cos'è e l'apice della
creatività e quel momento che il
risultato di uno studio risultato un
approfondimento in cui io riesco a
sentire qualcosa prima di vederlo prima
di poterlo spiegare in questo senso c'è
un grande legame tra arte e scienza è
stato è stato espresso anche prima in
questo senso è importantissimo però il
risultato di uno studio di un impegno di
una competenza di una conoscenza tale
per cui io riesco a vedere qualcosa
prima di vederlo voleva farà poi poi
condividerlo quindi una domanda che
finale ma siamo sicuri che per
realizzare lo stesso e ci manchi la
creatività secondo me spesso ci manca il
coraggio di mettersi in gioco la voglia
di uscire dalla nostra comfort zone la
pigrizia ci manca tutti questi elementi
e poi diciamo non siamo creativi io non
ci credo noi siamo creativi quindi il
mio augurio è per essere creativi e
felici perché la creatività molto a che
vedere secondo me con la felicità è
quello di dire mettiamoci in gioco le
sbagliamo proviamo paura ogni giorno
importantissimo non abbiamo paura di
aver paura
sentiamoci soli abbracciamo le crisi e
dubitiamo sempre giochiamo con le parole
importantissimo le parole le parole
esprimono c'è una parola per tutto e
avere una prova per tutto significa
avere la varietà e la capacità di
esprimere qualunque tipo di pensiero di
sentimento di sensazione un laureato di
25 anni fa aveva 40 mila parola
disposizione statisticamente oggi un
laureato né a 20.000 malissimo
riprendiamo in mano vocabolario
perdiamoci in una varietà del
vocabolario cerchiamo quando non
sappiamo la parola giusta per dire
quello che vogliamo dire perché senza
parole smettiamo di cap di di poter
smettere di esistere
le cose che non vengono dette
inizialmente sembra una semplificazione
alla fine non sapremo più governare la
nostra vita perché non sapremo più
esprimere quello che proviamo e sarà la
frustrazione a vincere la paura è
l'immobilità usiamo le parole usiamo i
vocabolari
sbarazziamoci certezze per giudizi
abitudini trasformiamo il disagio in
energia creativa non abbiamo paura di
star male cerchiamo di capire perché
stiamo male cerchiamo di fare qualcosa
per cambiare questa situazione il più
velocemente possibile adattiamoci al
cambiamento il più velocemente possibile
questa è una soluzione creativa ma è
anche una soluzione per la vita
l'ostruzione permette ferme dal mio
punto di vista per riuscire a
raggiungere la felicità e quindi
facciamolo per noi e facciamo anche per
gli altri io chiuderei con una frase
secondo me molto bella di einstein la
creatività non è altro che un
intelligenza che si diverte e abbinata
ad iron man che ovviamente è un
divertimento ma anche una necessità no
quella di avere un modello quella di
sapere che c'è un eroe un qualcuno che
si comporta in una certa maniera noi
cerchiamo di essere un pochettino eroi
anche noi in tutte le nostre giornate in
tutto il nostro quotidiano e penso che
le cose potranno andare meglio
grazie mille
[Applauso]